if you've ever wanted a TV that blows
out all the stops or gaming then the
Samsung qn 90c TV is probably the one
for you while most phones might want to
get a TV that is nicely middle ground
and handles content pretty well this TV
right here does all that and at the same
time it focuses on gaming especially for
you next gen console owners including
the PC Master race
there's a key feature that is only
included in the qn 90c and that's the
144 refresh rates on these TVs but they
only come available with the 43 and 50
inch variants
hello everyone it's Gerald and together
with Bobby we've been checking out quite
a few TVs and displays between us at the
same time gig culture covers plenty of
topics from tactile toys so the next
video might be different from this one
while I'm a big fan of the s95c check
out the reveal in this channel the qn90c
is awesome in its own right it's easy to
not want Q LED which is Samsung's fancy
way of say mini LED because of the
general hype OLED gets
and there's nothing wrong with it
but the qn 90c brings to the table
numerous tweaks that will have you
considering twice when it comes to color
accuracy gaming features and anti-clair
technology so if you are the type
they'll be looking to be gaming plenty
this TV will be the one for you and
you'll find it works especially well if
you have a desk setup as the 50 inch
size will be perfect when you're
relatively close to the screen itself or
if you have a smaller living room bigger
is not always better especially when
compared to getting the perfect size
screen for your own situation
if you're wondering why our office
environment has changed is because we
brought in the new qnidc as our
dedicated gaming review display for the
next few months our workspace is usually
dimly lit to facilitate our preferences
however there's one window that directs
morning light onto the TV catching
zaki's attention with its anti-glare
capabilities
q and ITC outperforms all the TVs were
reviewed in off angle viewing although
Samsung's previous iteration the q890b
seems to have even better anti-glare
properties depending on your TV's
placement still the qnitc deserves
praise for its anti-clear attack
offering great off angle viewing minimal
Reflections and vibrant colors ideal for
gaming knights with friends even if
they're not directly seated in front of
the screen one of the few things that
you want to do once This TV has been set
up would be to get the picture settings
out of eco mode as it caps the maximum
brightness of this TV the Samsung qn90c
can hit 2000 nits brightness on SDR and
HDR so it gets plenty bright compared to
many of the top TVs in the market right
now for the best results we found that
the TV's movie mode does really well in
day-to-day use as a default setting and
we can get the TV even brighter by
getting deep into the settings going
into expert settings and changing the
HDR to mapping settings to active
you can also increase the contrast of
the screen to a high as well honestly
you wouldn't want to do that because the
last thing you want to experience is
staring into a floodlight while
sacrificing color accuracy as an
everyday TV the qnidc already has
accident color accuracy especially in
movie and filmmaker mode and if you want
to find a tuning Samsung has it all in
their Library settings menu onto gaming
which is one of the key highlights of
this TV and Samsung has spent no quarter
with this aspect all the HDMI ports here
are version 2.1 and get output at a
maximum of 144 Hertz so with the PS5 and
Xbox series X you're going to get a
maximum of 120 hertz which is pretty
much a limitation of the consoles if you
want to get 144hz you can to plug in a
PC to get those extra sweet frames does
this mean that you might have to cough
up enough cash for a graphics card that
costs more than a console aim we're
talking to the PC Master race Fox here
we don't do logic that well
Jokes Aside if you're looking to get an
Nvidia card note that g-sync is not
supported here but you still get the
best from the top tier freesync premium
Pro for the best HDR experience
with the new announcement of fsr3 we'll
see how AMD Works in conjunction with
the rest of the industry provide Gamers
with the best experience regardless of
their Hardware
the TV comes with Alm and vrr making a
gaming experience as smooth as it can be
at this point of time we cannot imagine
if any modern TV can do without these
features at all especially when there's
going to be some form of gaming done on
this TV Samsung has also included their
own gaming profile to the TV once you
have plugged in a console
on top of that if you're plugging in a
PC you're able to enable a super ultra
wide mode game view which gives you that
nice Ultra wide widescreen mode that you
enjoy on a desktop PC
and right here we have a laptop which is
today's sponsor this video is brought to
you by MSI meet the summit e16 flip
featuring the latest 12th gen Intel Core
i7 processor RTX 30 series graphics and
a 16 inch Quad HD Plus touchscreen panel
with a 360 degree hinge it lets you
unleash maximum productivity with up to
11 hours of battery life at just 2
kilograms the summit e16 flip offers
unprecedented performance and
functionality allowing you to work and
play anywhere anytime build wise the
Samsung qn90c is as elegant as most
modern TVs and it has a consistent
design language with the rest of the
Samsung TV family in contrast to the
Samsung s95c there's no one connect box
and it all simply plugs into the back of
the TV HDMI ports can be found on the
right side of the TV and the TV has
quite a bit of channels to help you
manage the cables but we're not quite
sure if they would actually fit the
thickness of most modern HDMI cables
from the front the bezels are slim and
small to encompass 3840 by 2160 display
and it looks great overall no changes
here when it comes to the UI and tizen
is one of the parts of the Empire
Samsung is still holding on to we've
said this before and we'll say it again
if we're coming from other TVs the curve
in which one discovers and explores the
menus definitely will need some time for
new users to get familiar with this
remote is Samsung's go-to design for all
the existing TVs and has grown onto me
after a few reviews but I still cannot
get over the fact that it is small and
can be some cause of concern and going
missing but the solar power back and
rechargeable USB are great design
options for all with the qnidc this is
probably one of the best non OLED TV
Alternatives that is bringing the fight
to the preferred display tag in the
market if you are looking to see what
the rest of the market might offer at a
lower price point then this TV might be
a good starting point especially if you
have gaming in mind so that's my
thoughts on the tvso haul do let me know
about your own thoughts in the comment
section below and do check out the rest
of our videos right here